the jordan peel documentary
that is four parts i recently watched
that and i was always
an admirer of yours but this documentary
was not what i expected
it also was a very long time ago i was
younger my perspective of it was
different back then um due to age and
maturity i mean i grew up so fast but
like
still i think society was different then
i think we are putting a new lens on a
lot of things how did we look at things
where do you think society is now in
comparison to where it was then i think
society has helped a lot to
actually looking through a different
lens because the metoo movement we have
you know a social movement
we have a campaigns like the y i state
um to help in social media also help
which actually social media is a double
h uh sore type of thing because it's a
good and it's bad because we can find
resources there i mean with a click of
your finger i mean everybody i mean who
doesn't have a cell phone now these days
right so they can actually reach out for
help and look for resources but
basically uh society has uh changed a
lot based on the you know me too and why
state campaigns and also
um people have become more empathetic
and sympathetic with issues on domestic
abuse sexual assault and marital rape
all of these women issues and the new
generations also you know bullying i
mean you know it's part of domestic
abuse so and we have a problem with that
too and on social
network in the internet um you know with
uh instagram and facebook and all of
that so i think society has learned
finally and education is the base the
core of everything so i i think it's
very powerful to educate to keep
continuing the awareness and educate the
public
[Music]
you